so this I love his next quote quote from
tank women didn't believe it when I told
them I had two dicks but then I took
them to the room they'd
see hey toes welcome to another episode
of Dum people Town population you
population
saki Saki and I love the way your name
is spelled I was a huge fan of the Saki
olymp ypics right no that's the SOI is
that the so what are you talking they're
doing it wrong they are doing it wrong
welcome to town buddy welcome oh my God
thank you for bringing me to town what
an honor course you know Jay and I are
like huge fans of your standup and I
just so nice and and Dan too I I'll
include Dan in that mix but i' never
like to talk for Daniel um we've had our
we've had really good Festival riding in
a van together yeah we have I'm a huge
friend of you all it's really every time
you're at a festival I'm like oh good
this is going to be fun than you you
have a great great energy that will be
on display in this podcast we like to
get to the dumb right away yes let's do
it where you got where you got our fans
send in the stories and this one is sent
in Sometimes some of our fans we have
like a a handful of fans that really get
to the stories quickly and they what you
do is you uh Daniel van kirkens clar
Brothers on X or Twitter uh and hashtag
D people town and then we can tell who
who sent them first okay so this
sometimes we get the same story sent a
lot yeah like there's L when it gets
sent 70 times the dumbest on you know
it's a gem okay so this one is sent in
by one of our favorite people who sent
it in carlen mcder at sheb Caren follow
her I hope she gets like a ton of
follows because of this thing she's a
wonderful person you ready for the
headline you're going to love this one
man with two working penises say women
didn't believe them until they saw them
yeah that's usually how things work yeah
other than Christianity and any sort of
organized religion people tend to not
they although that's the craziest thing
that aliens are here I was doing stand
up about this so forgive me if it sounds
but I also feel this way aliens are here
this's a real feeling I have not just
comedy M and no one cares I'm literally
talking about the same thing cuz I'm
obsessed with aliens me too no one cares
yeah Dan you think the aliens in Miami
thing at the mall is real oh you know I
was all over there know you that whole
thing is no you know why because of the
word Miami any other City I would be
like if that was even in like Mobile
Alabama 100% 100% I'm in in Mobile
Alabama you could have told me they came
up from the ground and I'd go I believe
but in Miami but like there's a whole we
were told that when the aliens came we
would all go to a mountain and play a
keyboard and we would you know uh this
is a joke but I this is the whole deal
Randy Quaid would detonate himself for
all of us like there would be a huge
deal sure they're here and no one gives
a [__] yeah and maybe well they have two
dicks I don't know we don't know and it
may be this guy all right way to bring
it back so a man with two penises has
opened up about a peni wouldn't it be
peni the plural penises what's this one
oh that's my Wednesday penis my
Wednesday penis how do you ride a bike
honestly you split you split them one
goes over the one but then you're
worried about thigh action look at all
these penises I still don't understand
how men run in general but um like I
still like don't got the you know what
you know what it is it's a it's a very
uh uh profound turtling effect Turtle oh
okay and also tight tight underwear
probably really helps when PE like when
women try and wear something tight to
bring that old UC remember that old UCB
sketch I think it was was it besser or
Walsh and he was like a person that was
born with a
Don running and it's all blurred cuz
it's just yes okay so this guy has two
and he says shockingly No One Believes
him until they see it right so we
finally opened up about his condition
Blair so the truck driver from Los
Angeles guys we might get a chance to
meet him please from LA City of Angels
let's have him on the patreon city of
Broken Dreams known as tank that's his
name I shouldn't it be something like
two tanks double barrel yeah it should
be double shotgun what we call this guy
Double Trouble uh tank has dip phia
which is what it was called dpia which
meaning S2 penis penis peni while this
might seem like a gift does it seem like
a gift no I don't think it sounds like I
don't know I mean do they both work at
the sh can I ask you guys are we all
picturing side by side shot like double
barrel over one was coming out of his
head no I'm saying do you picture over
under or are you picturing side by side
side by side but it might be over under
over under would be over under is way
more beneficial to straight life right
uh so I now I'm going to tell you I
don't know who wrote this article and
I'll check back in if it was a man or a
woman times right Jason and I wrote it
together we wrote it the
Atlantic um no but like it's you will I
want to get your opinion if you think
this is clearly written by a woman okay
so this like has a female bent to it in
a weird way uh b anyway while this might
seem like gift it wasn't as good as you
might imagine you talking to me [__]
shade uh I suppose it might listen to
this this is the writer I suppose it
might be handy if something happens to
one of them you have a spare just in
case however there are a lot of
potential problems that could arise out
of this highly unusual condition peeing
must have been a nightmare yeah cuz you
don't maybe you don't know which one
which one's are coming out are you just
double two hot dogs in a bun you're just
holding Dan one is hot water and one's
cold water yeah are they both getting
rocked up or what's happening here
blood flow as soon as he faint every
time he gets a heart made that who was
telling that story uh was that uh Jeff
Ty's thing about being bricked up oh
bricked up oh no that was um who was n
AB bricked up all right soed up peeing
must have been a nightmare some men have
enough trouble uh aiming accurately with
just one that's how you know it's a
woman who wrote this article two would
be a whole another level not fun are
they rhyming this thing like this is
yourself in a li like an X like a like
an xxx Dr Seuss the man with two dicks
the dickle MC fickle or whatever I would
not pee on this A penous letter you read
did you say I would not pee on on a fox
I would not pee in a box right but I'll
do both at the same time yeah in the
train and in the rain okay however uh
for tank the condition which affects
about one in how many people ooh get
have double dick have double dick
syndrome one in how many people 5 mil
okay what do you
think man that makes me feel like it's
com I've never heard of this before in
my life was double dick from Harry
Potter yes Dumbledore sorry he was the
guy I'm going to say I'm going to say
one
in 5,000 okay 5,000 that's all that
happens a lot okay go ahead I think it's
1 in 50 million okay get your answers in
Townes one of you is exactly right no
[__] so now we get to play the game do
you want to stay at 5li was your 5
million 5,50 mil you're going to stick
on 5 million I'm going to stay were you
going to stick stay I'm going to hold
hold to hold
hold imagine this is a lot more okay he
has uh this it affects one in five
million go Blairs walks in and knocks it
out of the par Michigan baby that's
right national champ so you might
imagine having two things would make a
lot make things a lot more exciting in
the bedroom dep Department do you call
it the
department this is my this is my bedroom
Department I would like you to see that
would be so good we've had a few bedroom
the bedroom Department guy who hasn't
had sex in a while we've had a few
layoffs in the bedroom Department well
that's a problem we're not getting laid
off enough yeah I I just don't want to
hear the word
downsizing in the bedroom because
usually it's like this is where the
magic happens where we do all the
departmental work no this is and then
after you have sex with your partner
your partner's like listen I'm going to
need you to speak to human re
yes Regal manager here we're doing some
reshuffling at the top the department in
the bedroom Department however for tanks
Partners it's often an unpleasant and
awkward during the ACT I think most
women are like stop doing this to me in
general okay question I love we've done
stuff like this before love that we have
a female here yes
please thank you diversity incredible at
what point in dating someone do you say
I have two dicks got be like date one
appetizer of the first date I think I
think first date you go hey just you
know what no once you no second date
when you know you're going to get
physical I think it's second date but by
the way just to um the men out there if
you're watching here like second dat
getting physical on the second date is
crazy like I've known you for one hourra
crazy yes it's not enough what depends
on what you're looking for yeah exactly
I think second date though because like
you you didn't have to be like before
you even said hello where they didn't
even get to know you to know if they
would be willing to invest in your
double dick um department and you know
what else too it's not it's it's it's
it's it's towards the end of the second
date going really well right so you're
like oh we're definitely going to hook
up maybe the next time we see each other
like or or who knows at least he
probably feels guilty if he's like
really hitting it off with it if he has
a conscience now his name is tank and
he's a truck driver I'm hoping he has a
conscience okay he goes against type but
what I'm saying is that he he what if he
like really hits it off with the person
this is like by the way could be a
romantic comedy like you don't tell her
you don't tell her and then you know
yeah I mean I guess in this scenario for
tank best best case scenario it would
either be a a double vagina woman or or
a gay man a gay man would love a two di
man right a girl into double penetration
that that is down the table too but do
you say I have a disability or I have an
abnormality or it let me spin different
about me I just need you to know there's
something how do you tell let's play a
game you tell me something interesting
about you and I'll tell you about my two
dicks can't eat phaf we're going Tod
we're going to do two truths and a lie
but one of those is two
things but one of my truth is a two is
actually two truths in one yeah and do
you have any um bonuses that You' like
to tell any bonus body parts B you to
say what you think is the weirdest thing
about you and then I'll go how many
fingers do you have you got 10 that's
normal right be fun if you had like one
more all right so this next paragraph is
unbelievable this is again sometimes
sometimes Blair the people in the story
are dumb sometimes the people who react
to them are dumb sometimes the cops are
dumb sometimes the people writing the
article do [__] that you're like what is
this indeed tank said that many women
didn't even believe him after spending
eight years in a juvenile Det Attention
Center from the age of 16 for
manslaughter he was detained to enjoy he
was determined to enjoy life when he got
out they just gloss over did you so did
you I need you to say my listening
comprehension you know after all these
years is not great honestly if I was
born with two dicks like I could see
it's a clear path to murder you're like
I got murder in that P come on Dan sorry
I'm not anyway wait Ram what did say the
sentence killing it after spending 8
years in a juvenile Attention Center
from the age of 16 for manslaughter so
so he really [__] up as a kid he
screwed up he was it was too much to
bear honestly she's she's you know eight
years she's trying to juen he really he
went down a bad path as a kid so this I
love his next quote quote from tank
women didn't believe it when I told him
I had two dicks but then I took them to
the room they'd see what room the
department sounds so murdery bedroomart
that is and then I took them to the room
to the department right this is
something like a a talking head on 48
Hours a department all right so not only
that and they went to that room they
went to the room that room had more
surprises than she would ever know
coming up believe it on two in the hand
one in the
[Laughter]
book that's what it would be D found
that found that that was so good so not
only did but tank revealed that even
okay when only even when only one of the
two penises was in use the other one I
guess he'd hang an out of order sign on
it he would still ejaculate out of both
with the one not in use feeling like it
would explode okay so he's double orgasm
yeah double rainbow double rainbow I
mean if he found if kids find out about
this you're going to get picked on
mercilessly I know so this Mur origin
story is
Joker this is a this a Batman villain or
it is Johnny Tommy two times so
intrigued it literally tanky two times
I'm going to say this and this will make
sense uh having two penises and
manslaughter go hand in hand yeah well I
think having one penis a lot of time
leads to murder like it's a sure bet
look you're just thinking with your
dicks here
man don't let your dicks control your
life tank revealed that at least one uh
of these ladies was thrilled by his
extra appendage with tank saying she
became hooked I think he meant she's a
hooker right no just kidding tank said
she wanted to be a porn star and she
wanted us to do a video together I
probably would have made a lot of money
so you're saying you didn't do it you
would have I oh this is like you know
that guy was like I probably could have
played you played a sport in college
like I'm sure you knew people was like I
could have played in college like I just
didn't want to you know oh yeah people
that say that all the time oh yeah or
the worst one people who almost joined
the military yeah I should have I just
didn't want to shut up or every guy this
not one woman has ever come up to me
after a show and been like hey like
right you're barely even off the stage
and they're like hey all my friends say
I should be a comedian and it's like oh
that's so good you should do that let me
refer you to the Department of Comedy
yeah how about you don't share that with
me right after I finish yeah like I'm
not even my foot is not even on the
stage like you can't even let me enjoy
the great show I just did cuz what
they're saying to you is like yeah you
were fine but like my friends tell me I
can do it yeah yeah but like I don't
even it doesn't even offend me because
they're so unaware and I'm always just
like wildly polite to them I'm like it's
not going to be me there's a part of me
that always wants to go come back
tomorrow
8:00 you have 10 minutes you're 10
minutes you have 10 minutes and I'm
going to bring you up I'm going to go
out there I'm going to say this guy was
here last night he was in the audience
he told me he could do this and you know
what bring all your people well that's
the other that's the other thing he's
tomorrow night probably not going to get
all of his people there right and then I
go he was out in the H he told me could
do this so you know what we're going to
find out for the next 10 minutes clock
got it here we go he gets on stage and
he's like guys I ladies gentlemen I just
got to tell you something really special
about me I was born with two two
penises although some of Partners enjoy
tanks double Endowment in the end he
decided it would be a better option to
have one of the P penises surgically
removed defia is a genetic condition
that can have a lot of implications
outside of what you can see externally
while the condition is treatable it can
lead to other pelvic Health
complications for tank the best decision
for both himself and his future Partners
was to remove one of his penises and get
it bronzed I'm kidding why would I do
that I would leave it in the drawer for
later yeah Department um property that's
right I mean at least do one of those at
home molds so that you have it in some
you got to get a mold mold what are you
going to let that thing disappear
forever now you got to Archive the
Museum of Natural History yeah it's just
like that he's being so thoughtful now I
mean like I understand why he's out you
know on parole yeah cuz it's like if
he's like you said if he's thinking I
got to remove one of these things he's
being more he's learned what he
Rehabilitation yeah yeah he Mar condo
this [__] I mean look I I say
one you cleaned it out it's all F have I
used this in the last three years throw
it away it's it's it's called a
hungwe there we go that is Story number
one let's
go me okay all right awesome let's do it
uh up with Story number two we'll take a
break uh we'll find out what Blair's
doing how you can support Blair and
please don't come up to her when she's
doing and tell that you friends think
you can do standup comedy cuz I'm going
to tell you she's funnier than you we'll
be right back with more Blair saki on
dumb people town we are so happy let's
go
around hey guys welcome back to the show
before we get into Story number two ran
let him know what are you guys doing
what are you guys doing we'll tell you
what we have going on um we have so much
stand up that we were doing by the way
we just got back from Portland um where
we did helium which was so much fun and
and like just Joy of all Joys Kyle Canan
and Jeff Tate they're there in the city
they come down hang out with us watch
the show which is so sweet like the
nicest thing in the
world guys Greg Nibbler oh Greg nier and
Sarah Dy they're so nice so to all those
people who came out and all our
important people came out Jord open for
us he Inc
hilarious and then uh we did the wet
City Comedy Fest in uh Seattle which is
the first time they did it great Fest
hung with Whitmer Thomas who is
fantastic and really fun to hang out
with and great on music he's fantastic
his songs are like I think and we talked
to them about coming back and maybe
doing um like live dumb people town and
we'll do standup and you'll do stand up
there with no at the wet City Comedy
Fest next year when they do it we love
those guys love Seattle so than to that
we're going to Alaska but might drop I
don't know when this is going to drop
that it might be after may I think no
this drops a little L if it drops around
Denver we're going to Denver at the
beginning of February at uh com work
South and then at the beginning of uh
March we're going to be at Markley's
Comedy Castle the beginning of April
we're at Detroit in Detroit then in the
beginning of April we're at acting
Comedy Company then we go Tois in
Minneapolis and then moon tower so
super.com check all that stuff out Blair
what can people see got special got a
special oh yeah I would I would love for
you guys to check out my special it's on
live nation's new platform beeps their
new streamer and it's called live from
the big dog and uh love it where did you
do it I shot at The Bourbon Room M oh
here here in La uhhuh beautiful it looks
gorgeous it does look gorgeous I'm
really I'm really happy with it it was
really fun like how was the crowd the
crowd was amazing all my friends came
out it was my parents first time ever
seeing me do stand up yeah so that was
really crazy more nervous for you as a
standup or when you like were playing
college uh volleyball well this is the
first time they were like acknowledging
me doing standup so uh very different I
think I think this is like the first
time they were proud maybe since
then yeah they were they didn't want me
to do stand up I don't think but you
know like she they see this and it's
like no she can do it my dad it was
really sweet and it was like hard not to
be affected by it but he had like tears
in his eyes oh my God as a dad I get
that get it but it was like this is
after never wanting to see me do stand
up or anything so it was like a huge
like you turned them around yeah yeah so
aming oh my God I love this so now you
guys have to watch this listen to the
emotion behind this thing I love it so
it's what's live nation's platform
called this it's called veps yeah they
just launched like own app or streamer
yeah um and Brad Williams I believe did
a yeah they just launched their first
rounder special is David Cross Katherine
Ryan um Mo wch yeah great people Brad
Williams and it's out right now people
can go watch yeah it's out guys go watch
this special I love it Bo say it again
live at uh live from the live from the
big dog on veps can find it in any of my
Instagram um website and Twitter all of
that and we say Blair saki but it's s so
CCI just so you know and you and you'll
be at moon tower any other live dates
come on oh yeah well I just pushed a
bunch of dates so I could have a a
little um break after the special but I
think my next thing is sketchfest and
then I'm just at the store really every
week same we'll see you there we'll see
you there that's amazing all right let
me get into this story this was sent in
by Brew pounder at Brew pounder okay uh
here's the headline dirt bike rider
speaks out after leading state troopers
on Chase what's he speaking out about
press conference
style dirt bike rider I'm a dirt bike
rider and I have some words about breast
what's the song He's a dirt back Rider
Pinball Wizard pin wizard he's a he's
got he a dirt her he's a dirt bike
riders Got dirt in his mouth I love yeah
the audacity excuse me Mr J back
Christian manur CN CNN yeah because I
love the thing of like there's some
things I'd like to say about the cops
chasing me than you for coming here
today that's like on The Bachelor when
they list their jobs and like they
literally they're like former High
School swimmer and you're like that's
not a
jobob bike rider is like their title and
you're like that's
your yeah Travis Pastrana fine you want
to say dirt bike rider I'm down yeah if
you are an ex games of F and if you've
been in a halfpipe all that did you see
what our friend Jimmy sent us this like
screenshot of like USC's basketball team
and it had like Isaiah ker who's point
guard 14.2 points per game six assists
per game this other big star on their
team 18.2 points per game and then the
third image on the page was bronny James
and it just said team player
really he's like our dirt back rider
dirt rider dirt just the hubris all just
the hubris is I'm just a
teenage Rider oh that's great I'm just a
teenage dirt bike rider dirt bike sounds
like a a slur all right uh video release
to the fox 8i team shows how state
troopers chased a dirt bik a dirt bike
see you can't do it in Cleveland for
over how many hours they got to get a
little bit more horsepower in those cars
huh I know I feel like a dirt bike can
go places that cop cars cannot sure so
this thing was like a three-hour Chase
three hour chase a three hour she's
going to be like 5 million hours she's
right no I'm going to go uh I'm going to
go two two hours what do you think and a
half hours okay one of you is 15 minutes
away you guys want to go up or down 15 I
love what they said hours and then break
it and
245 uh 145 you either go 215 you want to
go 215 damn I was going to go 145 can I
align am I allowed to am I allowed to
align with Daniel you are 100% alive
because we guessed and it's he asked us
to you 100% allowed to align with danan
but had you gone to 215 you would have
been right
no 15 minutes so you were closest off
the gate trust yourself yeah I know
she's the closest I'm learning I'm
trying to learn that you're learning
what you're doing all right so this is a
classic example of some of a newspaper
writer who um a journalist who doesn't
have an editor okay opening line it
happened last week what what happed such
a great indirect reference when my kids
write things I'm like you can't say you
have to refer to what the what is it
that sounds like the first line of a
novel
you know where you just want to like
what the and the eye is huge and then
the te is small and the rest it knew it
couldn't keep doing this like what okay
it happened last week the video was
captured by a crew with an Ohio State
high highway patrol helicopter the video
shows the Troopers in the Air Track the
dirt bike uh for troopers on the ground
for 2 hours and 15 minutes um in the
video you hear he just pulled a U-turn
in the middle of the intersection and
just blew the intersection you can see
the dirt bike going the wrong way on
streets cutting through fields and more
the IT team went to see the most
annoying thing about it's a motorized
dirt bike right yeah no I think it's a
probably gasoline dirt bike right it's
like you're oh yeah youan most annoying
thing to me
about 2 hours and 50 minutes of oh my
God I have I have a deep I can I don't
even like the word hate but I have a
deep hate for loud motorcycle guys and
loud Car Guys yes cuz I'm just like who
the hell do you what we trying to prove
are who where do you get off just run
I'm trying to talk to my mom on the
corner of the street okay she can't hear
[__] cuz of
you it one night we're doing the standup
show at UCB and a motorcycle goes by UCB
Franklin so [__] loud like it sound
like it went through the theater and
coll was on stage and he like lets it
pass and he
goes there goes that
catch well one time I wrote a tweet um
that I I said like uh love your loud car
you seem super sane and it went like
somehow super viral and then the loud
car people all came for me like on my
Instagram and my Twitter was like she's
making fun of us not I was like I didn't
know you guys were like a faction like a
group like a like a tribe A support the
idea of people who like the sound of
just rocks being poured into a bucket
like that and they just and you know if
you like it fine but to me I'm like I
don't like who made you feel small in
your life and then a j by gang did you
see this thing were like ion zering up
and he had to fight like 12 of these
little they on electric bikes they were
on electric bikes New Year's Eve we did
a movie with ir earing he could take
them he did take them I was proud of him
he's pretty one of them like hit his car
or whatever pry he's pretty bricked up
heed up all right both of his penises uh
the IT team went to see the rider this
guy's name I can't wait to hear it I
cannot wait to hear it well okay if
you're on a drip bike for two hours Chas
it tells me a couple things about you
one you don't have anywhere else to be
one your license is suspended and you've
got some sort of loophole with a dirt
bike nobody's like where's Jeff nobody
is saying that's what I'm saying you
have nowhere to be no to be 2 hours and
15 minutes and no one looking for you
yeah you don't have one house you can go
to where people go hide in here not a
garage uh you don't have like a
girlfriend was like honey we have
reservations at 7 no his name Willie
Levant Wily lant they went to find out
what he was thinking cuz it's kind of
French but it's kind of this is his
quote he didn't let me go you mean the
cop didn't stop chasing he chased me all
day long with that helicopter like are
you you shocked he's Rota and Good
Fellas with that helicopter so we asked
I mean this is like who are you riding
this for why didn't he just pull over
and stop he said he tried to make a deal
when the Troopers got close quote I
offered to let me go home let me go home
and put the bike up he said wait that
was his deal yeah well your bike's too
loud they couldn't hear [__] wiie so he
lets them catch up and he's like
hey let me go drop off my bike and
they're like no here's my here's my
offer to you dude this is what I will do
like in a car I'm going to put this in a
garage it's like that seen in Boogie
Nights what don't you understand about
this you give me the tape I go make the
money I bring you back I'm look he's
trying to just make it they're like this
isn't how this works just because you
have logic and it makes sense to you
right that's not it I going to make you
an offer you can't refuse also also it's
like somebody like trying to like
divorce with the kids he's like you're
not mad at the bike you're mad at me let
me put the bike away then we'll deal
with me Dan I was watch there was like a
TI get these kids to bed then we will
talk about how it's over and again he
was so confident that that plan was
going to get through I don't even heard
him say but you know that he was like
let me get home I'm going to take this
person yeah I'm good I love this so he
was so confident it's like reminds me I
saw a Tic Tac of a guy who's like and it
just the title is so funny it was like
bro thinks he's a math wizard whatever
and someone was like 8 times 12 or
something and he's just like it's 91
this guy's like he's like he's like it's
91 and then he's like I he's like it's
91 and then he's like I just get these
math things and I just do them in my
head and I just know exactly what it is
the numbers just come to me I was like
dude that's wrong yeah that's the one
thing about math is that it is not
interpretive there is one it's an exact
science yeah right it's 91 I get these
things in my head that I just sort of
I'm a Willie lavant yeah all right
lavant sounds like Savant all right
numbers are relative like no that's time
he's an idiot lvon all right we reminded
lvon it didn't sound like he understands
many people are fed up with the dirt
bikes on the streets because they're
illegal that's what I'm saying she has a
problem with it we're not really in the
streets we're in and out and I don't get
what's illegal about wait wait they go
hey dirt bikes are illegal out on the
streets he goes not really in the
streets we're in and out in and out of
the street isn't every car in and out of
a parking spot or a garage or a driveway
at just you're in the street you're
admitting that you're in the street I'm
in and out I'm in and out no but that
means but then he wraps it up with a
foolproof dumb logic where he goes I
don't get why they're illegal that is
like just the thing now too where it has
become so popular that if you literally
get tried indicted like prosecuted for
something people will still just be like
no I didn't do that yeah no right just
deny deny deny you guys have the problem
with it it's not me it's 91 Guys numbers
come to me and they just they come to me
all right he says uh Cleveland Garfield
no other officers mess with me it was
just State Patrol Chasing me that day so
he's like he's got now he's he's trying
to say the other cops they're cool with
me and it's these damn stadies classic
triangulation classic Willie leavon
little bit of whataboutism yeah exactly
totally Dam uh the video also shows how
it finally ended when the dirt bike ran
out of gas after two hours on the run
and lavant surrendered the chopper
called out he's out of gas going to bail
laying on the ground lay it on the
ground he's like yeah ran out of gas
leavon said to the IT team at the end of
the chase that dirt bike rider got a
ride to the county jail but he ended up
released with no charges oh my God so
he's in the right he have to shouldn't
he have to pay for the gas however that
does not mean he's off the hook simply
Troopers plan to put a case together and
come back to the Justice Center for
grand jury on felony Char so no bail for
this lant reacted by saying I ain't got
time for that felony charges stuff
that's why I'm chilling like it ain't
worth it for a bike is this his defense
I really don't know and it's like I love
how he acts like it's his choice right
he like I'm actually not interested in
the felony charges not into it he is a
character in trailer park was like 100%
got time for this F I'm picturing a
character from King of the Hill yeah
he's like you know he's like you know
I'm actually just I'm good I'm actually
just going to chill right so no I'm no
thanks not your call Willie statue of
limitations is like 6
hours all right here you ready for more
Troopers say that the writer also had
some drugs and those those drugs are now
being tested of course Leon said says he
did not have drugs or a weapon like no
one said Anya weap you're now bringing I
don't have drugs or a weapon we
don't I do not have a 9 mm okay under
the seat I don't have a blowing knife in
my sock I don't no one said so don't
even try and look it's not my dad
chilling it's not my dad's gun it's not
it's not an unregistered gun whatever
record show though on Thursday he pleed
guilty in kyoga County Court to carrying
a concealed weapon yes unrelated
unrelated you're saying one thing to the
press and one thing to the a sentence of
time already served in jail we will get
out of here on this how old is Will how
old is the dirt bike rider himself dirt
bag
rer B of willly Blair you can go first
or we can guess and then you can go
after us whatever you what do you want
shoot cuz like it could be it could be
like a 24 but I'm going to go up I I'm
going to
go I'm going to go
30 I'm going to go 38
38 cuz you do have to be young enough
for that's long that's a that's that's a
lot of 38 38 damn I I'd say 19 19 oh
Willie Lamont's I like your first I'm
going to go 24 not a lot of willies at
19 I understand that like jly won would
have been it but Willy Wonka uh weasel
knel 38 I God you said trust yourself
and 38 was my second guess but I think
I'm going to switch it what do you want
no I can't I going to stay switch it
switch it if you want switch if you want
to switch it what were you thinking
first what 22 okay 22 22 19 and one one
of you is one year off okay so I'm going
to go 20 I'm I'm going Jordan 23 you
want to do 21 that way we can just old
sure sure yeah let 2021 23 okay we'll
get out here on this and then Dan will
do the third story Willie Levant is 21
years
old you got to go with the got the first
time we guided you to the right place
but you were there yourself I'm glad you
trusted your initial gut One More Story
with Blair saki uh Dan's going to take
us home and he'll tell us what he's got
going on after the break we'll be right
back with more dumb people
[Music]
Town
people hey guys welcome back to the show
Daniel before you take us home I want to
know what you've got going on uh first
of all say congrats to you guys on the
national championship you're we did it
we're all repping institutions ComEd
state I'm repping oair Wisconsin
wrestling dude my nephew declared uh
yeah he declared he's he's like the top
recruit for oair wrestling shout out
Tommy tudo love you Tommy tudo boom boom
baby gone tomorrow okay here we go gone
to oair Dan say what you're doing tell
us what you're doing oh I got a whole
bunch of dates go to Daniel vk.com I'm
going to be in DC Cedar Rapids uh de Mo
um all over the place I'm forgetting
stuff right now uh yeah watch my movie
wine club uh uh it's great um you better
like me if you watch it cuz I'm the lead
uh but it's it's a lot fun I've seen the
trailer and it's so fre good thanks
hopeful you guys are in town you're
invited to the screening um what else oh
oh uh my special comes out in April Rose
Gold so check that out we'll we'll pimp
that out big time as we right I think
our fans are going to show um but go to
Daniel vk.com oh this is the can I just
say this really quick I'm
sorry uh my I have a brand new website
it just launched Daniel van.com all new
completely red done not like a reface
built up from the ground up green Ivy uh
creative did it uh her name is Aaron she
is amazing she's a dum people Town fan
she's a pen pal fan and she was like
dude I'm doing your website I'm going to
fix it for you uh she is awesome if
anybody listening to this is like I want
a dope website go to scroll to the
bottom of Daniel van kirk.com and you
can do it here we go ready yeah Redlands
man pays in cash for fake gold bars this
is so dumbb people Town dude that is the
saddest thing I've ever heard that is
sadder than the double dick
murderer manslaughter manslaughter not
murder manslaughter manslaughter is that
a diff is there a DI Big Time murder is
like I'm killing you minimum 25 to 30
right is like I ran you over with a car
by acci is homicide yeah yes well the
homicide is still the result like
somebody was was killed oh but yeah it's
about how how a fault or how deliberate
you were in what happened okay okay I
thought man slaughter is usually an
accident or like I thought was
involuntary no okay all right I'm
getting off track also sometimes it
could have been it should have been
murder and it got pled down speaking of
our first guest let's get into the penal
code
twice double it up section 2 a rin's man
pays pays in cash for fake gold BS was
presented by Jake grony at Jake gron
love you Jake here we go officials have
issued Ed a public warning in the Inland
Empire this is local y'all about a scam
involving fake bars of gold after one
Redlands man was swindled out of
thousands in a scam Redland City public
information officer Carl Baker I mean
that is like the he should be the
information officer you almost assume
Carl Baker caraker car Baker who's the
Carl breaker of your
town yeah that should be a position at
the Poli Department whoot Carl Baker in
my city like people are always like with
kids like what do you want to be when
you grow up but really you should say to
them like all right so here's your name
let's start thinking about what will
work for you
yeah your name is Chase MC Skyman so
you're definitely going to be in the X
Games okay uh Redland City public
information officer Carl Barker said the
man who was scammed reached out to the
seller on
Craigslist yeah that's where I go for my
big money investment gold on Craigslist
is tier two I hate to say it cuz it used
to be tier one in all of our
Lives it is the only reason to have a
Facebook account that is Facebook
Marketplace that's right I know and then
it's Craiglist if someone is selling
gold bars on Craigslist run I'm not
trying to victim blame but you are
getting what you signed up for they're
probably filled with chocolate like if
you're lucky you're it's like eating a
steak at Sizzler it's probably not steak
Yeah you know what you're getting right
they're calling it steak they're say
it's he met the seller guys okay I don't
want to blame this victim but he found
somebody selling gold bars on Craigslist
then he met the seller in a back alley n
oh God damn it no literal back alley
deal I'm getting a deal y'all literal
backy deal met the seller in a back
alley on two occasions to purchase gold
bars for a total of how much money how
much money do you think this guy spent
twice he didn't buy one and then realize
these are fake he bought one then again
met a dude and an Al and bought two gold
how much money do you think he spent you
know it's in the thousands I'm trying to
think of how much one gold bar would
cost I don't but remember this guy's
probably given a deal right which is why
he's selling them and they she going to
say cool 5 mil I know what she's
thinking I'm going to
say my first instinct was 10,000 but I
feel like that doesn't make sense I'm
going to go 20,000 20,000 I think like
$6,000 enough that like it's bad this
guy's going on Craiglist $4,000 4,000
one of you is
$1,000 off 5,000 five I'll go to three
three should I have gone with 10,000 no
you you're you might you may be 1,000
off you may only be 1,000 off okay I'll
go 19,000
19,000 he purchased gold bars twice in a
back alley for 21,000 oh my God you've
been around it all
day you're so good at this that's crazy
that's bizarre I don't know I guess I'll
go this is like a Kevin Pollock run cuz
he was as good as psychic but you might
be psychic but also
$221,000 is insane 21 in a back alley I
have a joke in my hour rose gold where I
talk about going out to a gravel parking
lot with a guy named Gary to a van and I
always say hey that's white privilege
nobody else should be going to any van
in any
part no one needs to be going to do
anything in a back alley wait so this
guy obviously a drug dealer cuz why
would he be he's a gold bar dealer
searching for gold bars cuz he's like oh
I can't have all this cat yeah he wants
to launder he's trying to launder that
put in bars inflation I got to get my
gold bars those don't ever Che later
learned that the P the the the gold bars
that he purchased were fake I'm going to
show you guys as best I can when the
gold rubbed off and it was a
brick this is what they look like
they're like in a package almost like a
thick oversized credit card that looks
like like a Wonka right or like a little
like a little external hard drive
yeah we believe this is from our good
buddy Carl Baker We believe there may be
other victims out there and that that's
part of the reason why we're reaching
out we would recommend if you are going
to do something like this that you would
meet at a reputable dealer where you
could have the product tested right then
and there yes so anytime you buy jewelry
from anyone you can meet at a jeweler
and you may have to pay 20 bucks 50
bucks something for them to like inspect
it it will be worth it to you yeah to do
this 100% it's unclear why the buyer
didn't have the gold tested first that's
where it's on them you buy the first why
are you buying a second I think Blair's
right this is someone who's doing
nefarious stuff but but but then he's
even more dumb because he called the
cops to say I bought fake gold
bars they're like why didn't you go to
the Gold Bar store then dummy yeah yeah
cuz they they won't trade me for what'
you
say what' you say cuz I want to ride my
dirt bike around this what's the problem
if a deal is too good to be true it
usually is said Caesar Meyer the owner
of Crown gold exchange in Redlands again
perfect Caesar Meer you go to Caesar
Meer for the gold exchange if you're
looking for a buyer come to Caesar
Meer take a
flyer Crown gold Not Gold Crown Crown
gold exchange in rins cge Meer said
buyers can test the gold simply by using
a magnet did you know this I didn't know
this if you just take a magnet and put
it up to a piece of gold if it somehow
sticks for one reason or another then
you know instantly it is not real fake
it's fake wow I did not know this what a
great thing to know now the business
owner also said the gold bars will have
the weight imprinted into it and if the
weight doesn't match up again it's most
likely fake these are great ways tell I
know we're kind of like learning
educational as H car thank you if no
this is Caesar Meer oh thank you Caesar
Meer if you are being offered this under
the price of gold that is right there
it's a huge red flag he added that the
biggest red flag however is dealing with
a seller who wants to make the exchange
in a back yes right all right well I got
to cancel something after this is
supposed to meet someone behind here
she's buying a Nissan alley behind here
investor investigators are still trying
to identify the seller he was seen
driving a green Honda Accord to what I
said that's what you're selling gold
bars out of and goes by the name Sparky
Randy oh God no it's you dude I [__]
caught your ass guys come in come in
okay guys anyone with information
regarding the individual is being asked
to contact Redlands Police that's Story
number three goldbar Randy if you see
him take his ass down and and you can
take that to the bank says Meer Caesar
Meer from Crown gold exchange in didn't
Caesar Meer write all those movies about
old women falling in love with Old
that's Nancy yeah Caesar Meer talks to
uh dogs with three legs that's Caesar
Cesar Milan that was our joke that we
never so that I love this joke we can't
tell we don't really ever do it anymore
Caesar Milan got got divorced so I guess
he can't make everyone stay that's
hilarious that's a great and then I was
like or or come or come that was the
problem J you needed two penises all
right uh Blair Saki the special again so
people can watch it on veps is from the
big dog recorded here at The Bourbon
Room on veps check it out you love her
on this podcast now go support her as a
as a comedian and you'll come back and
do this again because we just love it so
much thank you so this was a revelation
at the time of my life and you might be
psychic yeah and you're and you learn
that you have I don't know math numbers
just come to me 5 * 6 74 91 it just
comes to me in numbers and I understand
it all right guys we love you thanks for
supporting us and uh oh [__] we got to
get back to
[Music]
work
town